salut à tous Comment ça va aujourd'hui
je vous parle de ce smartphone qui est
dans cette boîte c'est le Motorola c'est
le Edge 40 pro le Edge 43 était présenté
il y a pas longtemps et bien évidemment
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bien on prend ici
pour le réception on va donc regarder
plusieurs choses la première chose c'est
est-ce que Motorola est dans les clous
est-ce que Motorola est toujours
d'actualité est-ce que Motorola est une
marque est intéressante aujourd'hui en
2023 et ça croyez-moi c'est vraiment une
bonne question et puis surtout on va
venir regarder si ce Edge 40 pro vaut le
coup s'il faut venir l'acheter oui non
quoi comment ou pas du tout on va tout
regarder il y a des points positifs je
vous le dis bien évidemment heureusement
qu'il y a des points positif il y a
également quelques points qui sont
négatifs ce smartphone des choses qui
sont bien mais des fois on en voudrait
un peu plus donc est-ce que vous êtes
prêt on y va aujourd'hui pour faire un
tour complet de ce Motorola Edge 40 pro
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
tout se situe ici dans cette boîte alors
regardez je vous explique parce que il y
a un truc qui est quand même intéressant
ici que nous fait Motorola et que tout
le monde ne fait pas et bien c'est que
vous avez ça vous avez votre bloc de
charge qui inclut ça c'est un bloc de
charge qui est extrêmement rapide on se
parle ici de turbo power 125 watts de la
recharge qui vous emmènera aller en quoi
en 7 8 minutes à 50 % et puis vous le
recharger mais pas 20 minutes jusqu'à
100% alors je vous l'ai déjà dit dans
une vidéo précédente ça sert à rien de
recharger un smartphone jusqu'à 100%,
vous le laissez charger entre 20 et 80
pas en dessous ou pas au-delà comme ça
vous présenter votre batterie et ça
c'est bien et ça on aide donc ça c'est
cool donc déjà le fait que vous disiez
ce gros bloc de charge à l'intérieur
c'est vachement cool mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là puisque vous avez votre petit
câble qui est là bien évidemment pour
venir le recharger c'est le usb-c USB
c'est ça c'est cool merci Motorola et ça
ne s'arrête surtout pas là parce que bon
faut quand même pas s'arrêter là vous
avez surtout une coque de protection qui
est fournie avec donc ça c'est quand
même assez marrant Motorola et vous nous
mettre une coque de protection ici on
aime bien parce que effectivement et
bien vous avez tout ça qui inclut à
l'heure où de plus en plus de
constructeur mettre de moins en moins de
choses à l'intérieur et bien de leur
packaging là vous en avez pour votre
argent le budget je vous le donne tout à
l'heure vous allez voir il est aussi
assez intéressant voilà comme ça vous
savez tout sur ce smartphone d'un point
de vue packaging le packaging matériaux
recyclés il y a un côté un peu green il
vous le mettre là si vous regardez cet
appareil se recycle reprise à la
livraison des points magasins ou à
déposant des chatteries donc c'est un
smartphone qui se recycle et ça on aime
bravo Motorola alors moi je constate du
Edge 40 pro lui-même le S40 pro c'est
aujourd'hui le smartphone le plus haut
de gamme de Motorola Horse smartphone
qui se plie horizon ça je vous en ai
déjà parlé l'année dernière c'est donc
un smartphone qui est cool pour
plusieurs choses déjà il a un design qui
est très élégant on est sur un petit
noir mat comme ça que je trouve vraiment
super mignon super canon donc ça c'est
vrai quand même il est chouette le truc
qui est intéressant avec ce smartphone
c'est que vous voyez bien qu'il soit
quand même relativement long on le prend
bien en main une fois de plus il faut
regarder mes vidéos vous savez que j'ai
pas des mains hyper hyper grosse j'ai
des mains normales peut-être comme ça
sache comme ça donc j'ai pas des mêmes
bûcherons pour autant je le prends bien
normal ça c'est cool ça c'est le point
positif ou négatif il est quand même
vachement glissant ce smartphone parce
que lorsque vous le prenez comme ça
faites gaffe autant on avance ça va
venir adhérer un petit peu autant
l'arrière ça glisse un peu c'est une
petite savonnette alors avec sa coque de
protection ça ira mieux mais bon voilà
et l'autre truc qui est cool ici c'est
que ça smartphone qui fait un peu moins
de 200 g vu la taille vu le format je le
trouve pas très lourd donc ça je trouve
ça extrêmement confort et ça quand c'est
confort on aime pour autant vous avez un
cadre alu qui veut dire participer à la
légèreté du smartphone et vous allez
surtout un verre Corning gorillazictus à
l'arrière mais également à l'avant qui
vient vous le protéger alors vous le
voyez un capteur d'empreinte digitale
qui à mon goût est positionné un petit
peu trop bas je t'aurais préféré un peu
plus haut donc lorsqu'on vient garder et
poser son doigt comme ça il y a un truc
qui est pas naturel ah je le pose en bas
bon pour moi il aurait fallu venir
mettre par ici vous voyez ici c'est la
bonne position vous prenez vous peser au
niveau du maintien ça aurait été bien
mettre en bas seulement d'une petite
gymnastique bon après on y arrive c'est
pas très grave mais c'est pas ce que je
préfère alors là je vous présente en
noir mais il existe également en bleu
c'est d'ailleurs ce smartphone vous
intéresse je vous mets un lien quelque
part en bas dans la description alors ce
smartphone il se destin à qui alors il
se destiné à toutes les personnes qui
veulent un smartphone je dirais pour
faire un peu plein de choses à commencer
par
cette gamer que vous voulez une bonne
expérience 165 Hertz vous avez vraiment
un truc qui est cool et qui tient la
route donc ça c'est vraiment bien alors
c'est bien pour les gamers mais pas que
pour les gamers parce que si vous voulez
de la fluidité parce que vous allez dire
scrologue votre smartphone et bien vous
l'aurez ici en 165 Hertz alors pour
autant ce que je recommande c'est de le
mettre en automatique parce que 165
Hertz ça vient consommer sa tape dans la
batterie ça c'est pas forcément la bonne
idée vous laissez bien au taux et tout
ira bien alors puisqu'on est ici sur la
partie logiciel sur une petite
parenthèse pour vous en parler on est
bien évidemment basé sur un Android 13
ce que je viens approcher chez Motorola
c'est que je trouve ça un peu de terme
vous voyez c'est un peu sombre c'est un
peu tristoun alors bien que vous ayez
des petits blocs qu'on va venir repérer
pour comprendre un peu les différentes
parties qui ressortent et ça c'est
plutôt bien et bien il y a pas d'icône
de couleur rien et je trouve que pour
l'oeil c'est un petit peu tristounet
c'est vraiment dommage après pour venir
modifier votre fond d'écran ça c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal fichu vous
avez différents styles du dynamique et
compagnie bon moi j'ai choisi ça je le
trouve assez sympa c'est assez joli mais
vous voyez que au niveau de l'expérience
même dans les paramètres bon c'est un
peu tristounet après vous avez un tiroir
d'application qui fonctionne qui a un
grand classique et puis voilà c'est de
l'Android alors je veux qu'on revienne
sur notre écran parce que notre il a une
grosse particularité qui est vraiment
bien c'est qu'il y incurvé des quatre
côtés comme ce que vous avez avec le
Honor Magic 5 Pro à savoir que il va
être incurvé sur le haut sur le côté
gauche côté droit mais également sur le
bas ça permet d'avoir une fonctionnalité
intéressante c'est que lorsque vous
voulez poser votre smartphone à plat et
bien lorsque vous recevez une
notification vous avez une alarme et
bien il y a une lumière qui va arriver
sur tout le contour et qui vous
notifiera qui vous donnera l'information
ça c'est cool lorsque vous êtes
notamment votre vibreur que vous êtes au
travail vous aurez l'info c'est rapide
c'est pratique ça c'est chouette bravo
Motorola 11 paraissait d'un écran qui
est certifié hdr10 plus 1 milliard de
couleurs donc la dalle elle est cool et
pour venir regarder du contenu
multimédia pour donner les défiles des
séries pour jouer vous avez vraiment
quelque chose qui a parfaitement bien je
vous montre ici au niveau de mon teaser
vous voyez l'incurvé il y a des gens qui
aiment d'autre qui aiment pas lorsque
j'ai Zoé voyez il y a un côté un peu
plus de profondeur sur le haut bon moi
je crains pas je trouve ça assez sympa
par contre je n'ai pas en plein écran je
reste comme ça alors vous l'entendez
peut-être je sais pas si vous allez vous
rendre compte mais le son est quand même
pas dégueu regardez donc en fait le truc
c'est que vous avez un son qui est quand
même relativement fort relativement
pêchu donc ça pour venir regarder du
contenu multimédia c'est bien donc un
écran qui est totalement aussi adapté à
ça donc on est sur un smartphone qui est
totalement adapté au contenu multimédia
tout en sachant que je vous conseille
pas de venir écouter avec les écouteurs
bien que ce soit du stéréo c'est bien
mais ça va s'améliu de chez vous si vous
êtes dans les transports en commun vous
allez plus facilement privilégier des
écouteurs en Bluetooth ça tombe bien
vous avez du Bluetooth 5.3 à l'intérieur
donc il est totalement actuel par
rapport à ce qu'on trouve sur l'ensemble
du marché donc voyez pour l'instant ce
smartphone il colle vraiment bien à tout
ce qu'on trouve sur le marché il colle
si bien que on a le même processeur que
tous les flagship actuellement en Apple
bien évidemment parce qu'ils ont leur
puce propre or Huawei et or Google ici
vous avez un stade dragon 8 Jen 2 c'est
donc aujourd'hui le processeur le plus
puissant qu'on retrouve sur Android et
ça fonctionne super bien vous en avez
beaucoup plus sous le capot que ce dont
vous allez avoir besoin donc pour tout
ce qui va être gaming ouverture
multimédia ce qui va être applicatif ça
marche bien c'est pratique c'est rapide
à un détail près qui m'a un peu
chiffonné mais je vous en parle dans
quelques instants tout en sachant qu'ici
en plus vous avez 12 Go de RAM et 512 Go
de stockage vous avez vraiment de quoi
faire alors la batterie 4600
milliampères heure c'est bien mais peut
mieux faire l'autonomie est plutôt bonne
donc clair vous allez garder une bonne
journée une journée de nuit ça va
dépendre de vous et de vos usages bien
évidemment mais c'est pas le smartphone
qui aura la meilleure autonomie du
marché alors une fois de plus j'ai
tendance à dire qu'on s'en fout un peu
parce que vous avez votre blog de
recharge 125 watts c'est rapide c'est
pratique et si vous voulez il est
compatible charge sans fil 15W donc si
vous voulez le brancher directement
comme ça et bien on peut le faire
également ça c'est quand même pas mal
aussi point qui est intéressant et que
propose motor
ola et difforme alors le redis fort
c'est quoi c'est pas forcément quelque
chose dont vous allez vous avoir besoin
mais plus pour les entreprises ça permet
à Motorola de venir draguer des
entreprises et de récupérer d'autres
parts de marché le rediffor c'est quoi
la poésie caster votre contenu de votre
smartphone directement sur un téléviseur
en miracast ou à vous le branchez
directement
USB HDMI c'est pratique ça permet si
vous êtes gamer de venir jouer
directement sur votre télé pourquoi pas
mais ça permettra surtout à des
professionnels de pouvoir utiliser leur
smartphone comme un petit ordinateur et
vous lorsque vous êtes en mode
bureautique pour prendre un petit
clavier souris sans fil on branche tout
ça et vous pouvez venir bosser de
partout où vous voulez directement avec
votre smartphone au cœur donc ça c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal fichu alors
vous me direz ça c'est cool mais le
ready force pas forcément fait pour tout
le monde et on s'en fout un peu ce qui
va nous intéresser c'est la partie photo
alors cette partie photo parlons-en
justement parce que je trouve que
Motorola est venu améliorer sa même si
aujourd'hui elle est pas encore parfaite
regardez vous avez un double capteur ici
ici vous avez deux modules photos de 50
mégapixels grand angle ultra grand angle
et vous avez un téléobjectif de 12
mégapixels ok tout en sachant que le
téléobjectif en dira également pour
notre portrait et que l'ultra
grand-angle servira pour le mode Macron
et puis à l'avant vous avez une caméra
de 60 méga pixels alors le pixel pour
les pixels on s'en fout on va donc aller
tout de suite le résultat première photo
spéciale dédicace à mon pote Brandon
qu'on retrouve ici salut Brandon coucou
à toi alors on va commencer à regarder
je trouve que les photos prises sur le
grand angle sont bien ils ont vraiment
fait un très bon boulot alors bien
évidemment ils sont aidés par le saint
dragon 8 gène 2 qui va améliorer tout ça
grosse puissance de calcul de Lia
derrière donc forcément ça bien joué on
s'en doutera ici mais c'est vraiment pas
mal à l'ultra grand-angle est un petit
peu moins bien forcément on va voir un
peu moins de piqué mais on comprendra
bien évidemment vous allez voir qu'il y
a aussi une petite différence de
colorimétrie même si là c'est pas très
très flagrant alors après on peut bien
zoomer mais sur un verre de ce prises
globalement on s'en fout attention la
vue d'alcool dangereux pour la santé
consommé bien évidemment avec modération
et avec des amis alors là je vous emmène
à quatre séries c'était il y a pas très
longtemps je voulais shooter en
intérieur en extérieur vous voyez que
globalement le taf est fait grand-angle
ça fonctionne l'ultra grand-angle
forcément mettre un peu moins bon et
après on peut bien zoomer vous allez
voir que en venant zoomer sur Sarah
Michel Gellar qui était l'actrice
totalement de Buffy contre les vampires
et bien c'est pas ouf le téléobjectif il
est pas dingue dingue dingue c'est un X
2 optique ça sert à rien de venir
chercher trop dans l'image il y a
beaucoup de bruit c'est pas terrible le
mode portrait je trouve pas mal
globalement le détourage est bon c'est
bien fait on le fait bien évidemment à
partir du tel objectif et je trouve ici
le job est bien fait et globalement les
photos qui sont pris sur le grand angle
elles sont bonnes bien qu'on a le soleil
en pleine tronche on voit bien le
bâtiment ça fonctionne c'est bien exposé
dans une zone plus sombragée dans une
zone plus claire ça fonctionne bien
l'ultra grand angle aussi fait le taf
elle fait quand même plutôt pas mal ici
après on peut venir zoomer mais il voit
rapidement lorsqu'on zoom on perd
rapidement qualité et on vient oublier
ici c'est pas mal aussi une fois de plus
l'ultra grand temps je trouve qu'il est
quand même pas mal la voyez on vient
switcher entre les deux alors ça c'est
un truc que j'aime pas du tout je trouve
sur lequel il Motorola a vraiment pas
bien bossé c'est la caméra de selfie ça
vient de vous lisser la peau
regardez-moi ce teinte bébé que ça me
fait là c'est pas beau enfin j'aime pas
personnellement il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui vont adorer ce genre de
très culturel on retrouve plus en Asie
personnellement moi je suis pas très
très fan d'avoir des peaux très lissés
j'ai l'impression de alors de gagner un
peu en âge mais bon il y a un moment
c'est pas naturel c'est fake et j'aime
pas ça à l'intérieur il a eu aussi un
petit peu de mal au niveau de la caméra
de selfie vous voyez au niveau des des
teintes de peau lorsque l'éclairage est
un peu plus complexe il a eu un peu de
mal alors vous avez une petite option
pour passer sur un plus grand temps au
niveau de la caméra de selfie c'est
toujours bien évidemment le même capture
de 60 megapixels c'est pas ouf on est
très orangé ici et voyez que lorsqu'on
passe ici sur la caméra normale grand
angle plus standard à l'arrière et bien
c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus joli
ça fonctionne beaucoup mieux et ça c'est
cool alors l'ultra grand-angle est un
peu plus de mal et on voit un peu la
limite dans ce genre de conditions là
qui sont un peu plus extrêmes avec les
spots un peu partout donc là c'est
pareil on regarde un petit peu la
cérémonie avec une série vous voyez le
grand angle qui marche pas mal qui peut
aujourd'hui ultra longtemps qu'un peu
plus difficile et après on évite de
venir zoomer un peu la même chose alors
tout ce qu'on va faire en macro je
trouve ça quand même pas mal fichu on
les bien évidemment sur le capteur ultra
grand-angle on a 50 mégapixels donc il
peut venir s'exprimer pour venir
travailler sur la macro de meilleure
qualité et globalement le rendu est pas
mal alors une fois de plus c'est de la
macro pris avec un smartphone c'est pas
parfait mais bon c'est pas dégueu alors
les cette nuit sont pas mauvaises on le
voit comme ça il y a quelques mots ça
devient un peu poussif il est un peu
plus de mal c'est pas là où il va être
le meilleur soyons clair dans cette
gamme de prix une fois de plus dans le
tarif tout à l'heure si on veut vraiment
un excellent photophone on ira plus
facilement vers un pixel 7 Pro tout en
sachant qu'ici on n'aura pas exactement
la même performance brute on n'a pas eu
de gène 2 on est sur une puce de 2e
génération donc c'est quand même pas
tout à fait la même histoire qui se
raconte mais voyez là le ciel est tout
de suite beaucoup plus bruité alors pour
autant c'est joli sur la Croisette mais
là il y a beaucoup de bruit dans le ciel
donc bon la photo de nuit au why not
mais là ça voyait ça typiquement c'est
c'est dégueulasse là il y a rien d'en
sortir donc bon en photo de jour s'en
sort bien en photo de nuit c'est un peu
plus compliqué donc c'est un module
photo qui est pas mal mais qui reste
malgré tout en demi teinte ce qui est
cool c'est un smartphone qui a du wifi
6e et qui est compatible pour le wifi 7
donc dès que le wifi 7 arrivera et bien
lui il sera prêt et ça c'est bien on a
bien évidemment la possibilité d'avoir
une ici à l'intérieur et grosse
nouveauté chez Motorola et pas des
moindres et c'est ce qu'on s'attend à
voir sur un smartphone très haut de
gamme celui-là est bien il a une
certification
IP68 résistant à l'eau et à la hier et
ça croyez moi c'est quand même vachement
cool on l'attendait chez Motorola ça
finit par arriver donc ça c'est un très
bon point et le tarif me direz-vous dans
tout ça et bien il coûte 899 euros
avec le Motorola le S30 pro donc le
tarif n'augmente pas et ce qui est cool
c'est que vous avez en plus je vous le
dis votre blog de charge à l'intérieur
la coque qui est fourni donc Motorola
quand même bien bosser là-dessus ça
c'est cool après on est sur un
smartphone à presque 900 €, on vient se
rapprocher des 1000 €, il reste bien
positionné ce que j'avais reprocher
c'est quelqu'un avec quelques limites au
niveau de la photo et surtout le truc
qui moi m'a dérangé c'est que je
trouvais que lorsque je voulais shooter
que j'appuyais c'était pas réactif alors
ça peut être corrigé bien évidemment on
n'a pas de vue logiciel mais au moment
où je tourne cette vidéo ça n'a pas été
corrigé par Motorola donc lorsque je
vois et que je veux venir déclencher à
plat mais comme par hasard d'ailleurs ça
va être rapide ça va être actif ou que
je viens changer le mode vous voyez il y
a des moments où c'est pas très rapide
alors là ça semble fonctionner mais moi
j'étais frustré à plein de moments parce
que je trouvais que c'était pas assez et
pourtant j'étais dehors il faisait beau
il faisait jour je le prenais à vite et
merde ça pété assez rapide donc voyez ça
c'est des petits trucs à venir améliorer
d'un point de vue logiciel donc il y a
un petit peu de taf là-dessus Motorola
donc une fois que tu seras corrigé ça
sera bien mieux je pense bien évidemment
que ce sont des petites améliorations
d'un point de vue logiciel ça devrait
probablement arriver d'autant plus
qu'ici vous avez quand même trois ans de
mise à jour Android donc là Android 13
Android 14 Android 15 Android 16 et 4
ans de mise à jour de sécurité donc vous
êtes tranquille ici donc moi ce qui me
plaît c'est que je vois que Motorola
continue à évoluer j'ai trouvé il y a
encore deux ans ou un an au niveau
de la harpe là ça progresse là ça
commence à être sérieux c'est bien il y
a encore quelques petites choses à venir
améliorer d'autant plus qu'elle a
vraiment sous le capot de puissance avec
le syndrogue 8 gène 2 ils ont encore un
petit peu de taf mais ce qu'on a ici à
899 €, c'est totalement honnête donc si
vous ne voulez pas de smartphone d'une
marque chinoise si vous voulez un
smartphone d'une marque américaine sous
Android Motorola soyons clairs il y a
Google bien évidemment mais si vous
voulez un stade dragon Motorola je
trouve bien je trouve intéressant il a
encore quelques petites limites mais il
évolue et ça c'est plutôt chouette ça
c'est plutôt cool donc ça permet d'avoir
un acteur qui est sérieux sur Android
ici et ça c'est cool d'ailleurs je sais
pas vous ce que vous en pensez dites-moi
ce que vous en pensez de ce Motorola de
ce Edge 40 pro est-ce qu'il vous
intéresse oui non pas comme moi puis ce
qui est aussi intéressant à venir voir
ici c'est que Motorola ils l'ont
présenté ou mw6 j'en ai fait une vidéo
et bien c'est un smartphone avec un
écran qui vient s'enrouler d'un côté qui
remonte de l'autre côté ce qui est cool
c'est qu'en fait ils viennent montrer
qu'ils sont là ils sont sérieux ils
innovent ils ont le Razer qui est un
smartphone qui se plie qui est cool même
si aujourd'hui il est pas aussi sexy que
ce qu'on peut retrouver chez oppo chez
Samsung mais l'innovation là et il le
montre on en reparlera probablement plus
tard donc bien évidemment abonnez-vous
actionnez la cloche et puis surtout
dites-moi vous ce que vous pensez de ce
smartphone qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ce Edge 40 pro est-ce qu'il vous plaît
est-ce qu'il vous hype est-ce qu'il
pourrait vous botter est-ce que vous
pourriez l'acheter marquez moi ça bien
évidemment dans les commentaires et puis
nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler de texte donc d'ici
là prenez soin de vous embrasse et
beaucoup d'amour Ciao
[Musique]